hi I'm Patti Harrison no one likes you
and I'm joking booster is that true and
you're watching and send where we
celebrate the best and the worst of the
web but mostly the worst so let's jump
right into Unzen come on everybody the
water's fine I'm already damp you're
nasty watch your volume
[Music]
[Applause]
our social media profiles really define
and brand who we are in what we want to
say to the world and I gotta say you and
I are really delivering on queer Oh
bodycon Asian futuristic ravishing
demonic laugh out loud piss come
squirty squirty yes
today our brand is tight but was it
always that's why we're digging into
vintage socials and asking the question
defend or delete so first I'd like to
just start with this tweet that you shot
off in 2015
sorry I only do butt stuff with verified
like why did you think this was okay
historian 15 was a different person then
I I think I have a different point of
view now I wasn't verified then oh I
didn't know what verified people were
like I made a mistake same coz I guess
like my question is it's like what did
you think verified people were like
thangkas you do know that like you can
have like 400 followers and write one
article for HuffPost queer voices and
you can get verified these days you know
it's super easy
I thought verified people were better
yeah I still do what's what's going on
this is your Latisse you up again yeah I
can only say I'm really sorry so you
would delete I would delete so Joel we
have this first post here the caption
says it's not delivery
it's the $7 DiGiorno that they put in a
microwave for me because we're all
trapped on this train and have no other
options hashtag train life there's a
broader contest here I was trapped on an
Amtrak train from New York to Chicago
for 27 hours and I didn't have any other
food options so I had to buy the food on
the train and so this is a comment on
capitalism and train life again it's
funny it's funny I'm funny Joel I don't
think you should delete it hello I agree
with you
thank you and one thing that you didn't
actually talk on that I thought was kind
of pretty cool is that you took this
this iconic slogan from DiGiorno it's
not delivery its DiGiorno and you spun
it in this kind of academic way where
everyone was like reading it and they
were like it's not delivery they think
they know it's fire okay four years oh
my god and York oh my god Joel I know
what you're doing and I'm and I'm gonna
accept all of that that you just said at
face value because I am smart and I'm
good I'm funny and I'm worth it stop
it's my own personal religious belief
that dying is so bad but you know what's
the best very good seeing random
celebrities insert themselves into a
memorial of the deceased that is fun
it's very good so let's take a moment to
comb through social media condolences
and memorials in a segment I call oh my
god
[Laughter]
here we go gonna start off with my girl
Kirstie Alley who gave us this
absolutely heart-wrenching tribute to
Stephen Hawking you had a good go at it
thanks for your input thanks for your
input Hawking is a world renowned
British theoretical physicist known for
his contributions to the fields of
cosmology general relativity and quantum
gravity yeah and Kearse he's acting like
Steven is her old nutritionist who
gently suggested cutting back on dairy
not a chance bitch I love sour cream
also I'm going absolutely wild crazy
cuckoo for this emoji riddle tweet from
cher to Steven it was amazing I know we
argued about the value of history share
when time travel is perfected history
will obsolete then we get into the
latter part of the tweet which is rhymes
and riddles in a potpourri of
punctuation history is like a friend
comma and new quotations hashtags are
like chicken emoji scratches to me
shocked face emoji capitalized dyslexia
r.i.p dear cat the d heart emoji no in
quotes girl pass me some of what you're
smoking the street is lit Gress okay
disgusting it's too much it is too much
it's all too much so I'd like to call
for an end to this behavior oh you mean
tasteless post about celebrity deaths or
hurt no death in general I'm against it
it should be banned no we can't we
talked about this this is not a
political show okay call your senators
vote then out vote who out the dead
we're here we're queer and we'll never
die we're here we're queer and we'll
never die
let's talk movies because here's the
thing we're Millennials really honest
I'm so young my skin is like a baby so
we don't have 90 minutes to spare to
watch any old full ass feature film heck
we don't even have time to watch it I
don't even have time to let you finish
your sentence droll I got most of it out
so let's review the latest streaming
releases using a method of criticism we
can understand our phones without doing
any research okay to be clear we're
gonna review movies based solely on the
thumbnail posters of what streaming
online okay movies yeah okay here we
have all right now with I believe that's
a Kobe Smothers that's her name right
can't read it but what I can't see is
miss Colby looking at me with her
smothering smolder and she's got a
leather jacket on baby
that can only mean one thing baby this
lady stays up late and yells cuss words
and tell us authority figures to kiss
her butts baby I'm frankly scared to
death of this maniac oh thank you
she's got a guitar in the background
swiping away a rational man looks like
Joaquin Phoenix which I gotta be honest
I'm always surprised when I remember
he's alive not that I have anything
against Joaquin Phoenix it's just when I
think about him I want him dead true and
Emma Stone with her eyes and rasp and
whimsy and Wonder I like those qualities
and a leading gasps same okay we'll give
this one up oh sure oh dang it
Patti dangit we'll see that thought that
old timey jazzy font the signature font
of an accused child molester hey just
about tricked us into watching on what
are y'all enjoying No thank you no more
pedophile movie for me okay I'll have
nothing to do with this trash Diddy
movie next and now we've got my friend
Dahmer huh
no you know they've already tickled my
interest because you know how I love a
movie poster with one big head looking
this way and then a little head looking
this way and then another head looking
this way it's very powerful plus
got pinkish use and a guy who looks sad
and misunderstood there's a sweetness to
this Jeffrey Dahmer and I like that
also his glasses are chic as hell who is
that lady staring at us underneath
guessing she's playing his mother
oh my goddess and hush I need this
nursery screen in the furnace yeah
what'd you put in my mouth
you know I am the gymnastics injury well
we did it
we sure did done do it we did the dang
yeah that's the end of our show and it's
Santa your life we uh what nothing
thanks for watching and send yeah bye
can we oh no I immediately feel bad for
doing that